a Texas man facing the death penalty
found an unlikely supporter fighting to
save his life one of the people he
wanted killed Bart Whitaker was
convicted of hiring a hitman to target
his own family his mother and brother
were murdered and his father was
seriously hurt a jury found Whitaker
guilty in 2007 of arranging the plot and
he was sentenced to death
his father Kent forgave his son and
fought for years to get Bart off death
row
Peter Van Sant gives us an update in
this week's 48 hours the Whitaker family
just seemed like the model typical
well-to-do Sugarland family Kent would
occur his wife Tricia and there are two
grown sons Bart and Kevin were returning
home after dinner on December 10th 2003
when that picture-perfect image was
shattered kevin opens the door there's a
huge loud noise bang kevin was shot
center mass right in his sternum Tricia
says oh no and I hear another noise bang
Tricia had made it into the house behind
Kevin and was shot and then fell in the
doorway but I look inside and there is a
figure with a ski mask on Bart didn't
chase the guy into the house I'm as he
approached that figure he was shot I
think oh my god he shot all four of us
well Bart and his father can't recovered
from their wounds Tricia and Kevin died
it became clear that it was a conspiracy
it was not a random act of violence
detective slot soon discovered the man
behind the conspiracy was none other
than Bart Whitaker a son who hated his
family so much he hired a hitman to kill
them all Bart had the hit man he hired
shoot him to cover up his crime in 2007
Bart was tried convicted and given the
death penalty I believe as a Christian
that God can and does forgive and change
people's hearts over the next 10 years
only one person fought to save his life
the father Bart tried to kill for
was my last surviving member of my
natural family and nobody in my family
wants to see him executed in February
2018 the execution date is set Kent now
remarried made one last desperate plea
for mercy to the Texas Board of Pardons
and Paroles we're not asking them to
forgive him or to let him go we just
want them to let him live just two days
before the death sentence was to be
carried out the board made its
recommendation the recommendation for
clemency
this was the right thing to do but the
final decision had to come from the
governor and when execution day arrived
there was still no word from him Bart
Whitaker had his last meal Kent went to
see his son for the last time
touched hands through the glass and they
said our goodbyes the clock was ticking
one hour to go would it be life or death
then Peter Van Sant is with us Peter how
unusual is it to have a death sentence
commuted in Texas it's very unusual in
fact Texas executes five times as many
people as the next closest state and at
the time that this appeal was made no
clemency had been granted for more than
a decade
Bart's show any remorse for what he had
done well I was in the courtroom during
actual trial and that was and he took
the stand he said he was sorry for what
he did but as i sat there I felt as
though it was just words his father said
during the course of his time in prison
that he did change and he believes he is
remorseful
so we'll see he's not a very sympathetic
fellow he hired someone to murder his
entire family to have his father as its
number-one advocate who's right standing
it was Brad never seen anything like it
Peter thank you thank you and you can
watch his full report on 48 hours
tomorrow at 10:00 9:00 central right
here on CBS